here's another thing to be enraged about
um CBS has this an NYPD Sergeant was
arraigned on manslaughter charges
Tuesday after his indictment was
unsealed in the death of a 30-year-old
man back in August in investigators said
that he threw a cooler at the man's head
during a drug bust the emotions were
High inside the courtroom for the police
officer accused and the victim's
families the local activists said that
it's the first step of justice for the
family and accountability for the system
the family of Eric dpre and local
activists uh um walked arm in-arm
outside Bronx criminal court Tuesday as
tense moments unfolded Dupri is probably
actually the name anyway
uh and we have the surveillance footage
so this shows the Duran this shows the
undercover um officer who was there at
the
scene when Eric dpri was um there he was
they were attempting to arrest him in a
drug bust and he fled on his uh on his
motorcycle scooter or whatever it is and
um the undercover cop to try to stop him
from fleeing through this cooler at his
head and and he fell off the scooter and
then he died uh we have that video
footage let's watch
that
okay so I mean it's an impressive throw
first of all that that thing was full
apparently was full of ice and water and
he picked that thing up and tossed it
and hit the guy right as he was right
it's like a moving Target
um that that so in a in a sane
world what You' be doing because you got
an undercover cop you got this criminal
he's trying to flee from the scene of a
crime um and there's pedestrians and
there's kids all around it's a park you
know it's it's it's a dangerous
situation already when you get into a
high-speed chase situation it's put
people puts people's lives in Jeopardy
and so you got this undercover cop is
going above and beyond the line of duty
and he's able to just mcgyver it and use
what's around in his in his in his
surroundings to stop this guy and so in
a sane country not only are you not
charging him with manslaughter but you
are giving him an award right this so if
it was up to me I'd be inviting this guy
and I'd be giving him a I'd be pinning a
medal on him um for going above and
beyond in the line of duty but we don't
live in a Saiyan Society especially not
in New York so instead he's being
charged with with
manslaughter
um and it's obviously an
outrage uh
it's the fact that they're going after
this guy for for not only doing his job
but again going above and beyond to
protect his community and subdue a
criminal it it's
enraging and really these situations are
remarkably simple or they should be like
people act like they're
complicated and but but it's not it's
actually very simple and that is that if
you get injured or killed by the police
while you are in the process of
committing a crime or fleeing from the
scene of one it is almost always your
fault and that is what the law should
say and that's how the court system
should treat
it then if you get injured or killed
by the police when they're trying to
stop you from committing a crime or or
um
or detain you uh Under Suspicion of a
crime you get injured or killed almost
always your fault now only in the
absolute most egregious most radically
outlier kinds of circumstances could it
be anyone anyone's fault but yours so if
this is
a uh who was it down in Phoenix sha
Daniel shaver this is like a Daniel
shaver situation where you have someone
who is the suspect and they have their
hands up kind of what they claimed
happened Michael Brown but that was all
a lie uh hands up
complying right and then and then
they're just executed on the spot by the
police well that's one thing then then
clearly in that case there should be
criminal charges
but outside of
that it's it's it's on you man like it
should be on you that's your fault and
if there's any if there's anything that
appears to be slightly over the line if
there's something that could kind of you
think it go either way there something
that seems a little bit I don't know
about that um I think in those cases it
should be Tai goes to the Runner every
time and in this case the runner is the
one who's not running the it's the
police right that should be if if if if
if there's any kind of like slightly
well I don't know and in this case and I
on this one I don't even think I don't
think there's anything that's over the
line I don't think it's anything that's
confusing or anything about it that
should give you any pause at all it's
pretty simple this guy's committing a
crime sup respective committed crime
they're trying to uh detain him he runs
away he's on a he's on a scooter and so
they they knocked him off of
it and then he died in the process whose
fault is that what are they what are
they supposed to do just follow you
until the gas runs
out and this is by the way this is this
is standard Now using a cooler is not
standard police procedure that was just
him being that was just him being
Innovative but you know ramming into a
car that's fleeing uh putting spikes
down all these all different kinds of
ways and and in you know in any
situation like that if somebody is is in
a some kind of vehicle whether it's a
scooter a motorcycle a car and they're
fleeing and you do anything to stop them
against their will it it it may injure
them or kill them whose fault is that as
we head toward a presidential election
in November there's one thing you can be
sure of 2024 will be a tumultuous year
how will your hard-earned savings Fair
well you're already seeing the impacts
of inflation at the pump at the grocery
store the dollar continues to lose its
buying power faster than wages increase
how are you protecting your savings
consider diversifying into gold from
Birch gold group for decades gold has
been the choice of investors in central
banks to hedge against inflation if you
have an IRA or 401K from a previous
employer that's just Gathering dust
called Birch gold and they will help you
convert it into an IRA in Gold you're
not going to pay a penny out of pocket
they will simply convert that 401k into
physical gold which unlike digital
currency cannot be tampered with it's
the most reliable thing you could do
just text Walls to 98 9898 and Birch
gold will send you a free info kit on
gold with an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau thousands of satisfied
customers and the exclusive gold company
of the daily wire for the past 7 years
you could trust Birch gold to just like
we do text Walsh to 98 9898 to claim
your free info kit that's Walsh to 9898
98 and secure your savings now like the
message should be to criminals the
moment you decide to commit a crime the
moment you decide to run away rather
than face the consequences for the crime
you committed you're taking your life
into your
hands and almost almost anything that
happens from that point is going to be
on
you unless again it's the most egregious
most clear case of just an actual
execution which they always claim BLM is
always he was executed no he wasn't okay
he wasn't this guy's an idiot got
himself
killed and uh and and to be perfectly
Frank with you it's not you know it's a
shame he threw his life away it's always
a shame but is it a great tragedy for
the community is the community you know
we always hear the community suffering
are they
really like to have drug dealers and
criminals that have taken themselves out
of the picture by their own
behavior is the community worse off now
without
them almost every single BLM martyr you
can
name it's just an objective fact I'm
sorry that their communities are better
without them because these are dangerous
criminals these are people who are uh
contributing nothing of value to society
and um and so it's there's really like
nothing to be in tears
about and except ex unless it's tears of
sympathy for this police officer who's
being charged with the crime for doing
his job um and uh it's just
it it yet yet another case where we are
we are rapidly getting to the point
where I I don't know
how
any I don't see how anyone gets into the
law enforcement business in the first
place I I just don't I don't know how
you do it they are making it impossible
to do and of course that
is by Design thanks for checking out
this video if you'd like to listen to my
full podcast on the go you can check out
the Matt wall show on Apple podcast
Spotify or wherever you get your podcast